okay so the directions are asking me to
measure two milliliters of hydrogen
peroxide so using my graduated cylinder
I'm gonna measure two milliliters of
hydrogen peroxide and I need a little
bit more and there we have two
milliliters of her of hydrogen peroxide
now I have to get a piece of liver piece
of freshly cut up liver I cut this up
earlier today bought a pound deliver
from the grocery store and I'm gonna put
a piece of liver into test tube number
one I've labeled my test tubes 1 2 3 4 5
6 so I'm gonna put a piece into test
tube number 1 and I'll probably have to
push the liver all the way down to the
bottom of the test tube with my stirring
rod here and let me turn the test tubes
around so you can see them better so
here we have on the far right this is
test tube number 1 okay now the
directions tell me to add the 2
milliliters of peroxide I'm going to add
the 2 milliliters of peroxide to 2 on to
test your into testing number 1 and we
need to observe the reaction of what
happens here we go
you can see that bubbles have formed and
the bubbles go almost all the way to the
top almost all the way to the top of the
test tube you can see there's some tape
at the top of the test tube here but the
bubbles go about an inch all the way to
about an inch to the top
you
asked to feel the bottom of the test
tube feel the bottom of the test tube to
see if it feels warmer or cooler to the
touch and by doing this I can figure out
if this is an endothermic or an
exothermic reaction and when I feel that
the bottom of the test tube I can feel
that the glass of the test tube is a
little warmer
you
okay so next I have to take test tube
number one again this is test tube
number one and I have to drain the
liquid in the test tube number two so
right now I'm just draining the liquid
they use the liquid in the test tube
number two and I'm gonna keep the liver
intestine number one for later so right
now again you can see I'm just draining
draining the liquid from test tube
number one I took the liquid from test
tube number one and I poured it in the
test tube number two okay now now I'm
gonna take test tube number two and
again using my forceps my tweezers here
I'm gonna take a fresh piece of liver
and I'm gonna add it to test tube number
two and we're gonna check and see if
there's a reaction and then I can use my
stirring rod to push the liver all the
way down and kind of get stuck the liver
is kind of sticky and fresh and raw so I
need to push it all the way down into
the used liquid at the bottom almost
there
there we go and if I hold this up you
can see that there there's no real
reaction this is test tube number two
there's no reaction okay so I'm gonna go
ahead and mark that observation in my
data table
you
okay so now I want to figure out is this
catalase the remember there's catalase
enzyme in this piece of liver and this
is test tube number one I've already
used this piece of liver once I want to
figure out is catalase reusable so I'm
gonna take some peroxide and the
directions again tell me to measure two
milliliters so using my graduated
cylinder I'm gonna measure two
milliliters and I need a little bit more
so using my graduated cylinder and my
eyedropper I can accurately measure out
two milliliters and there we go two
milliliters so I have two milliliters of
hydrogen peroxide in my graduated
cylinder and I've already used test tube
number one once but let's see what
happens when I put this brand new fresh
peroxide into test tube number one which
we've already used one so let's see what
happens you can see that even though
we've already used this piece of liver
once more bubbles formed so that should
prove whether or not catalase is
reusable and I would go ahead and mark
my observations in my lab handout
you
okay so here is test tube number three
and you can see I've added a piece of
fresh liver this liver has not been used
before and I covered it with a little
bit of water so a fresh piece of liver
sitting in some water and we're going to
see whether or not heat affects the
enzymes actions so in this boiling hot
water I'm going to go ahead and set my
test tube and I'm gonna let that sit for
the next five minutes so I'm gonna pause
the video right now and I'll come back
five minutes later
ok so it's been about five minutes I'm
gonna use my test tube clamp here to
remove the hot test tube from the water
so I don't burn myself and I'm gonna
carry it over to my lab area okay now I
have to let it cool off for a few
minutes because I don't want to burn
myself so I'm going to just set that in
the rack and I'm about to cool off for a
few minutes I'll be right back
okay test tube number three has cooled
enough you can see I can touch it and
not worry about burning myself and I've
already drained a little bit of water
that I added so the only thing in here
is the cooked piece of liver and we're
trying to see does he have an effect on
enzyme activity so I'm gonna slide test
tube number three into my holder here
and I've already measured two
milliliters of fresh hydrogen peroxide
and I'm going to add the fresh peroxide
into test tube number three and we're
gonna see if there is a reaction here we
go
when I hold it up you can see that
there's very little bubbles at the
bottom if any bubbles that are formed
from from this piece of liver and no so
I'm gonna make that observation in my
data table on my lab hand again test
tube number three the heated liver
heated for five minutes you can see that
there's very little bubbles if any
produced in this in this example
you
okay so now I'm gonna work on test-tube
number four and testing number four asks
that I obtain a chilled piece of liver
and you can see in my ice cooler here I
have some liver sitting in a beaker so I
can use my tweezers I can use my
tweezers to obtain a piece of chilled
liver
here's chilled fresh liver it's been
it's really cold it's been sitting in
the ice and I'm gonna put it in test
tube number four and so test tube number
four has a piece of really cold chilled
liver and next I'm gonna measure two
milliliters of chilled hydrogen peroxide
again this peroxides been also sitting
in the ice in the ice bucket all day so
I need two milliliters of it so I can
measure using my graduated cylinder two
milliliters of chilled peroxide need a
little more
to milliliters of chilled peroxide and
there you go you can see that I have two
milliliters of chilled peroxide so what
happens now test tube number four here's
again test tube number four it's got a
piece of really cold liver in here and
I'm going to add chilled peroxide to
this really cold liver does cold affect
the enzymes reaction let's find out
notice when I added when I added the
cold peroxide to the really cold liver
we still have a pretty good amount of
bubbles the bubbles go almost to the
same height as before you can see that
the bubbles have stopped maybe about an
inch from the top so even though the
liver was cold even though the peroxide
was cold there's still a high rate of
reaction I would mark this observation
in my lab handout
you
okay so now we're working on Part C I
want to figure out what effect does P H
have on the enzymes actions and ability
performance function so here is test
tube number five and the directions say
to add two milliliters of peroxide to
test tube number five so I've already
measured out two milliliters of hydrogen
peroxide and I'm going to add it to test
tube number five okay so now test tube
number five has two milliliters of
hydrogen peroxide in it and the
directions tell me to add a piece of
liver that's been sitting in this acidic
solution so here's a piece of liver
that's been sitting in the acidic
solution I'm going to add it to test
tube number five and let's see if
there's an enzyme reaction when I hold
it up so you can see better you can see
this enzyme there's various scuse me you
can see that there's very little enzyme
activity here because there's no bubbles
so test number five no reaction
whatsoever go ahead and mark that
observation in your lab handout
you
so now we're ready to move on to test
tube number six and the directions tell
me again to add two milliliters of
hydrogen peroxide have already measured
two milliliters of hydrogen peroxide I'm
going to add this into test tube number
six
so right now test tube number six has
two milliliters of hydrogen peroxide and
the directions tell me I'm going to add
a piece of liver that's been soaking and
sitting in this alkaline or basic
solution we're going to add this so I
need to pick out a piece there we go I'm
going to add this piece of liver that's
been soaking in the alkaline or basic
solution I'm going to add it to test two
number six now we're gonna look for
enzyme reactions here notice you can see
here come the bubbles they're coming up
pretty quickly and after only a few
seconds you can see the bubbles are
almost three-quarters of the way to the
top eighty percent of the way to the top
ninety percent of the way to the top so
we can see even though these pieces of
liver even though the the liver was
exposed to a basic or alkaline solution
we can see the rate of reaction is
almost to the top the bubbles almost
went all the way to the top of the test
tube go ahead and make this observation
test tube number six make this
observation in your data table
you